could the Stargate announcement happen
in October that's this October basically
in the next four weeks welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and move a
channel
[Music]
we have been waiting a really long time
there have been a couple of near misses
and even a false start or two but is
that all about to change are we about to
finally get what we want and finally get
the official announcement and a movie
and a series to then look forward
to how soon could this announcement
happen well at Sidra we've recently
reported that MGM had reached out to us
they wanted to open a dialogue with us
following two years of us leaking
exclusive after exclusive they hoped to
have a positive dialogue with us and
hopefully avoid much of the negativity
projects like rings of power managed to
generate they were able to confirm their
plans to go ahead with a movie either at
the cinema or straight to streaming they
haven't decided yet but it will be
followed by a series however it does
seem that the fact that they are
starting to reach out to YouTubers would
suggest something is coming soon there
have been a few more reasons though
while we suspect this is coming very
very soon maybe even in the next four
weeks the timekeeper game release so
slythering games are about to release a
Stargate game called timekeepers this is
a very exciting Mission Le game and has
been in development for several years
but it's nearly ready to release in fact
Slytherin press release office has
already been in touch with sidre and
offered to let us get access to the game
a couple of weeks early and review it
for them now we've heard rumors that the
game was purposefully delayed following
the sale of mgm2 Amazon this was in part
to adjust the story line to get it more
in line with the vision Amazon has for
the franchise but also to fit in around
the announcement of a new series or
movie but why would you delay the game
for that well for sales it's that simple
interest in the franchise and therefore
the game will obviously be far higher
following the announcement than before
it the game will be out in just weeks
will the announcement be first though
Stargate movie from 1994 came out on
October 29th at the time it was the
biggest opening weekend for a movie in
the box office for October ever and
Roland emerick's 1994 Stargate movie
starring Russell and sper is still mgm's
10th highest grossing movie of all time
it turns 29 on October the 29th but what
does that have to do with anything well
PR and marketing people are looking to
how to announce projects they do look
for certain things and one of the things
they love is an
anniversary companies regularly save
their announcement for special days Star
Trek loves to announce things on
Federation day or Star Wars has May the
4th if they can they love to release
something for fans on those special days
could Amazon decide to do it again and
announce on the original movie's
birthday big events like
ComicCon before the strikes hit Amazon
did have a plan several sources have
confirmed our exclusive that Amazon were
planning to announce the Stargate movie
at San Diego ComicCon 23 in March they
had already decided they couldn't do it
the writers seemed ready to go on strike
and they were pretty sure the actors
were going to follow so those brilliant
Executives over Amazon decided not to
announce anything during the strikes it
basically felt that if they did it would
make them look bad so now the strikes
are coming to an end are there any big
comiccons they could announce at well
yes a few weeks ago live we discussed
New York ComicCon that's the 12th to the
15th of October 2023 and a few days ago
gate World followed up with a brilliant
article raising the same possibility to
make it even better Amazon has a 2-hour
stage session set up where they are
promising to show never before seen
footage for fan favorites returning
shows and highly anticipated new shows
could one of those be Stargate now to be
clear gate world and are not saying that
they have any Insider knowledge here and
they are just pointing out the
possibility but from the sources that we
get to talk to over at citre we don't
think it's very likely to get an
announcement on stage in the Big Apple
for a couple of reasons for one MGM is
not actually mentioned in the press
release now MGM is owned by Amazon but
technically these companies merged and
legally in many ways MGM is still a
company in its own right there is
nothing to say Amazon would have to say
MGM as part of this press release if
they did intend to announce things like
RoboCop Stargate but it would be in very
bad form for them to do it it would
really be an insult to one of the oldest
and most loved Studios in Hollywood no
our sources are telling us that this
event planned by Amazon is just for
Amazon projects if starget is to be
announced MGM is more likely to get its
own time on stage separate to Amazon
where are you
going I don't
know
talking to one source they stated that
they wouldn't put it past Amazon to do
this but they think at most if they
decide to announce in New York a teasing
video is more likely a coming soon to
Amazon short video with hints of several
projects that might include a Stargate
opening not an official announcement
that would follow with MGM via press
release but perhaps enough to get the
internet
talking Amazon need a director and a
script first anyway though right well
our sources have been telling us for a
while that they have a script pretty
much done before the strike even if the
script is not quite final it's far
enough along that it wouldn't stop the
announcement but how about a director
well again you don't have to have a
director signed up before they announce
but they would prefer it announcing an
intention to do something is great but
you want to have something to announce
you want to have writers producers a big
name director if possible so why do we
think think this could be close if
nothing like that has been announced
well again thanks to our sources we have
found out that um one of the big agents
at one of the big talent agencies in
Hollywood dragged their entire team into
the office on Monday October 2nd
something they don't do very often they
got someone from legal to join several
discussions throughout the day as well
now why is that interesting well the
rumor unconfirmed of course is that the
agent in question specializes in
managing directors and producers and
according to the source all this
excitement was caused at Amazon's
instruction for MGM my source suspects
that it's very possible considering only
a week before an official Source at MGM
confirmed to sidre that they knew who
the director would be and when I asked
if this director had signed up they just
repeated we know who it would be
strongly suggesting that they had a
director in mind and had had
conversations with them but they were
not on under contract yet but maybe they
are now now that is a rumor and
conjecture I don't deny it we don't know
for certain what is happening but since
a source emailed me late Sunday a few
days ago excitedly telling me that it
was close that I should contact other
sources for more information as soon as
possible there have been several leaks
that together do start to build a
picture something does seem to be
happening now the strikes are coming to
an end and it is difficult not to look
at October and think this could really
be our time so Gators get ready six
Chevrons are locked the seventh Chevron
is engaged the gate is finally about to
open we hope if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification that really helps us
out you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to
patreon.com where most of our new videos
premere first and you get to see them
without the adverts also you can go to
s.co UK where we do articles based on
most of our videos and we try to add a
little bit more information for you to
digest as always please stay safe and
we'll see you
[Music]
soon